the pair is deal climate change
agreement which is very good it takes us
a step forward we'll have to ensure that
we work harder post Paris and implement
this deal and we're much more harder as
a universal agreement that has been
obtained as to as that each and every
one of us is a road so we've come to the
end week to actually day 15 here in
Paris everybody's pretty happy the
leaders have reached an agreement the
whole world is now on board under single
mechanism to try and reduce greenhouse
gas emissions and prevent global warming
so all is good up all night to cut
carbon all night to cut carbon
a moment of joy and a moment of relief
and a historic moment I mean finally the
world is going to come together and do
this as Francois Hollande said you know
the United Nations works and this is an
a peaceful cooperation of countries from
all around the world solve the world's
greatest crisis right now
we have a started a new process virus
has a liver and outcome we will always
like to see a more strength in a band in
terms of environmental integrity and
climate justice but we believe is our
building blocks that we should continue
to build upon in the next few years we
understand that the ambition is to be
implemented both in terms of radiation
emissions for us in terms of the
resources that need to be put it on the
table for implementation well the number
one goal we have here was to convince
all countries to support long-term goal
of one and a half degrees in case of two
degrees and we managed to achieve that
coming into palace we had all the rich
countries and all the big developing
countries not on our side in the 14 days
we were here we manage that all of them
on our side
I'm feeling very good it's an excellent
result so am I going to do I feel tired
I feel relieved but I also know that
I've witnessed something that's pretty
historic you know we don't know how this
is going to work it we don't know how
well it's going to work you know I
suppose I'll spend the next 5 10 15 20
years trying to figure that out but one
way or another this was a big moment